actually if you look at what the indians
have said they were very strong in their
condemnation of the atrocities in uh in
butcher
as i think everybody understands uh
india and russia have a historically uh
very different a relationship uh perhaps
and russia and the uk have had over the
last
couple of decades uh we have to reflect
that uh reality but clearly i'll be uh
talking about it uh to narendra modi
what we'll be focusing on today
uh the incredible opportunities to
deepen this partnership i don't think
any time in my political lifetime has
the uh the living bridge between the uk
and india really been so strong and just
on this trip we've got i think about a
billion pounds worth of investment
coming from india into the uk they're
the second biggest investor in the uk
that that investment loan is going to
drive 11 000 jobs we're hoping to
complete another free trade agreement
with india
by the by the end of the year by the
autumn and already you're seeing uh
products like
uk medical supplies
british apples uh
getting ready to come on to the indian
market even before uh the deal is done
and you know just look around you uh
this is a sort of example living
breathing incarnation of the
of the umbilicus between uh the uh the
uk
and india india and the uk this is
a world leading factory 60 000 diggers a
year
coming uh from india exported from india
to 110 countries but with with british
technologies you're going to approach
the ukraine question very gently but
russia india is very reliant on russian
energy russian weaponry is there an
opportunity there are you going to say
to prime minister modi for britain for
british arms manufacturers we are both
the interesting is both our countries
are excessively reliant on foreign uh
hydrocarbons and we need to to move away
from that together and so one of the
things that we're talking about is what
we can do to build partnerships on uh on
hydrogen on uh electric vehicles on
offshore wind uh on all the ways that
you can reduce the cost of energy uh for
people uh with with green technology and
and so there's a big opportunity there
but as you rightly say uh there's also
the opportunity for us to
deepen our security and defence
partnership as you know the uk is making
a an indo-pacific tilt
in the uh our integrated review of our
our national defense and security
strategy that's the right thing to do
given the huge portion of the world
economy that is uh and the growth of the
world economy it's gonna be found in
this area
and
india and the uk
both share anxieties
about autocracies around the world we're
both democracies and we want to stick
together well you talk warmly about
india being the world's largest
democracy but i mean it is an
increasingly authoritarian one plenty of
concern here about press freedom
protection of minorities bulldozers you
know we're in a bulldozer factory being
used to destroy the homes of muslims in
several states are you going to raise
these issues when you see
modi we always raise the difficult
issues of course we do but uh the
the fact is that india is a country of
1.35 billion people and it is democratic
it is the world's largest uh democracy
and it's an astonishing creation and
it is going places very fast and the uh
the opportunity for us to to deepen our
partnership deepen our friendship our
ties is enormous we're here in in
gujarat in the in the west of of india i
think there are about 1.6 million
gujaratis in the in the uk alone there
is a massive massive interconnection
between our countries you're a long way
from westminster today where the
lockdown breaking party saga will again
dominate the day you have ordered your
mps to delay a possible investigation
into whether you
misled parliament it's a really serious
matter why are you kicking this into the
long grass i'm very let me just say i'm
very keen for every possible form of
uh scrutiny and if the house comms can
do i think whatever it wants to do but
all i would say is i don't think that uh
that should happen until uh the
investigation is completed and that's my
only uh point i've said this time and
time again let's get the uh let's let
the the
investigators do their stuff uh and and
then knock this thing on there you're
committed to allowing a vote once sue
grey's report has come out once the mets
have decided how many fines they're
going to dish out parliament will have a
vote on whether to allow the privileges
committee to look at whether you misled
parliament so i think that's that's fine
but all i'm saying is i think that i
think what people should have is the
full facts and in the meantime what i
want to do is is you know get on with
the job here we are uh in uh a gigantic
new jcb
factory uh as i say in in gujarat and an
absolutely amazing example of uh
the the what's the word i want the
synergy the synthesis between uh uk
technology uh and indian technology and
what i'm going to be talking about with
narendra modi is all the ways in which
we're going to develop that partnership
and there's a there's a big appetite on
either side for mps who are discussing
your probity this afternoon in the house
of commons who are saying that you did
mislead them with all the statements you
made as these revelations came out
what do you say to them in the the
answer to that straight question did you
mislead the house of commons
knowingly or inadvertently
of course not but it's up to that they
must do whatever they they want that's
their that's their prerogative uh i want
to focus on the uh
amazing opportunities that i think there
are in the uh partnership that is
developing developing between the uk and
uh and india and
i i
talked just now to
a um
an indian
company that is interested in uh
building helping us to build yet more
offshore wind farms at a cracking rate
and that i think is something that is of
us which could help us uh build uh you
know add to the gigawatts that we need
faster than probably any other solution
that is the kind of thing helping to
reduce the
the price of energy helping to make
energy more affordable that's the kind
of thing more important the parties i
think you were trying to say you did
i'm just going to say reporting the
party gate that's going to say to you
humbly uh humbly that i think that that
is a uh what people will want me to be
focusing on right now but for uh for my
friends in westminster they must get on
with with
their votes that's fine prime minister
thank you thank you thank you